i can't i can't be bothered to like come
up with like exciting things like that
for streams like
which is why i'm always impressed with
like how recently you've been doing
i mean i feel i feel like at that point
you it's you have to treat streams the
ways the same way you treat youtube
videos yeah that's what i kind of
i do sometimes i mean right now when i'm
just playing like
like apex over and over again i'd
already see it that way but like you
know when i'm
doing certain things i do think of it as
like oh just think of it as if you're
making a video
right yeah and then just talk to the
audience that happened to also be
watching you make this video
yeah that's the way i see it i think
that when you think of it like that it's
a lot easier to actually make
good content live streaming but if you
have don't have that frame of reference
of
how does it feel to make a video because
obviously we have like five years of
experience of
talking to the camera yeah making a
video but if you've never had any of
those it's like how do i how do i
explain
how you should behave yeah good content
but then
i i think i've still like a lot that i
can improve on so i'm getting i'm
getting there i mean it's a different
treat
it's a different field but the way i see
it is that you know i think
either of us can become successful
streamers i just think
i i don't have the energy to put into it
because i would have to
i'd have to use the energy to put that i
put into making youtube videos into
making twitch streams yeah i'm like
cool i mean there's there's so many
youtubers who end up
just stopping youtube and going to be a
twitch stream or vice versa
yeah it's normally youtube has become to
me
the one thing that is just stopping me
from making that transition is the fact
that i wouldn't be able to take a
vacation yeah that that's like
youtube you know like i before i moved
to japan you know people
didn't know that i didn't do any work
for a month because i was busy doing
stuff but i prepared enough videos in
advance where
like everything was running perfectly
smooth you know right but i was able to
take a month off exactly like it was
just like oh my god that's nuts
you can't do you take a month off as a
streamer like
people don't know yeah you just
disappear off the face of the uh yeah
pretty much yeah yeah which is why like
i don't know right now it's just like a
fun little
side hobby right now but you know i i've
noticed that i
tend to i used to you know when i would
uh do youtube videos
i would once i finished with the video i
would think about all right what's the
next video i'm gonna make and i would
think about it all day
what am i gonna make what am i gonna do
oh i can make this i can make that
but like now i don't really think that
way i think like i plan what videos i'm
going to do
and i don't really think about them i'm
just kind of until the day comes or i'm
making it like all right trying to make
a youtube video
which i feel is more healthier in some
ways but it feels weird it feels like i
care less
yeah i think but i think it's a good
thing i don't know i've had to try and
change my mentality towards that
as well where especially hanging out
with you guys
and just all constantly compared to you
guys feeling like i'm
behind schedule and that's because i'm
i'm very like
my content is very like inspiration
based i find it so hard to work on a
video
if i don't feel like working on the
video i can't just like force the video
out so i have to basically try and
schedule
enough ideas ahead of videos i want to
work on
um in order for me to be able to meet
that like schedule
see i think inspiration is a little
[ __ ] i think i think when i kind of
you can't rely on inspiration at all
right i think you know if you did what
you did
for the bbc yeah you don't have a choice
view of inspiration or not yeah but it's
a different i mean it's making something
it's a different career path right i
mean it's comparing like a
office job to a creative path but but i
think for any creative field it's
important to discipline yourself
to well yeah it's something you have to
learn of course
it's just it you know if i get
inspiration it's fantastic i love it but
it's so fleeting and motivation is so
fleeting as well it's like
you just have to discipline yourself to
work i'm kind of like halfway in between
i think like yeah of course like if i
have to if you know time is
crunching and i have to record something
in order to make the deadline then
obviously regardless if i'm feeling
inspired or not i have to do it but for
the most
part it's like i wake up in the morning
and i think okay
do i have to record today then okay i'll
record but if i don't have to and i
don't feel like it i'm not gonna [ __ ]
force myself to do it yeah i mean
there's some days where my mood is so
bad that
i'm i'm close it's going to come off in
the video so i just don't want to do it
but
you know the other day but then also in
that time if okay if i was going to make
a video
i can't do that today i'll do something
else that's productive right for me to
keep on top of things
i don't know but like recently i feel
like i haven't really had that choice
because
i think the past like four videos i've
recorded this week have all been
pre-scheduled yeah on like certain days
uncertainty yeah i mean that's what i
try and do i try and
leave a lot of videos that are in the
works a lot of videos that are
ahead so there's always something i can
work on i don't i don't like to just
finish a video and be like
i got nothing what am i doing like
what's next huh like you know i think
it's i think it's good to have multiple
things you're working on it's like you
have to plan for the next one as you're
making the process yeah yeah yeah which
is also
quite difficult for the way i used to
work because i used to like i like to do
one thing at a time yeah same
thing but now yeah i've got now i'm
juggling like seven different videos
yeah
something like that quite a lot for me
i'm even either working on seven
or i have no idea what i'm working on no
in between
i need to change that but that's why i
feel like i i
find it so scary if i was a twitch
streamer because the twitch streamer you
you have to start streaming no matter
what mood you're in
and yeah i feel like it's so much harder
to hard
so much harder to hide that on a twitch
stream rather than a youtube channel
yeah because it's constantly on camera
yeah this is true i mean
i think the one thing that's even worse
than starting the stream when you're in
a bad mood is when your mood sours
mid-stream oh yeah
you'll start in like an hour and then
maybe you'll get like a text from
someone that's like
telling you like bad news yeah or maybe
someone will say something that's like
real [ __ ] mood or maybe something
yeah like the stream starts to go wrong
yeah like when stuff starts going wrong
whilst you're streaming it is
so much more mentally taxing than when
you're then starting the stream in a bad
mood because you're like
it can't get worse yeah yeah i'm already
in a bad mood well it's like
it's like [ __ ] up on stage in front
of an audience right yeah yeah
yeah versus just [ __ ] up in a
recording booth yeah right
right yeah it's it's big difference like
like some [ __ ]
clown no this actually didn't bother me
that much but like this is like an
example of something that could happen
so like
um whilst i was streaming one time uh
something happened on my discord server
where one of the mods made someone else
a mod who was pretending to be a mod
so someone joined my discord server
saying hi for some reason
uh i'm not a moderator anymore and they
have the same profile picture in the
same name as a moderator and
someone else on my server thought oh
yeah that checks out that makes total
sense i gave the moderator yeah and then
they start injecting a bunch of bots
into my server and started like spamming
it so my discord server completely got
raided
whilst i was streaming and the whole
purpose of uh this person doing this was
to do it to people who are streaming
live
so they get a reaction so i'm there it's
happening and
my ev all my chat is like connor connor
your [ __ ] discord's on fire
and i'm like oh okay right yeah i mean
it'll get dealt with
yeah yes yeah it's something you can
deal with later yeah that that's like
that but it's frustrating when i was
like bro bro you need to look at this
look at this thing i'm like
i don't really give a [ __ ] like i'll
deal with it later yeah
yeah yeah but i was good because that
guy was going around trying to film
tick-tock reactions of streamers getting
angry oh really i was like glad i didn't
know that at the time but i was like i'm
glad i didn't [ __ ] react cause i was
like oh okay cool
sounds like an [ __ ] dick thing to
move yeah who does this
don't do that yeah people want attention
right that's what it is nothing new yeah
nothing new in the world
you just got to deal with people always
uh looking to attack you yeah
i get that sometimes you know i get
every now and then these like obviously
people who are just coming into
twitch chat just to [ __ ] get a
reaction out of you just spam [ __ ]
yeah and the best thing i do that just
works is like i respond to them but in
the most
deadpan [ __ ] voice ever where it's
like you're normal
yeah literally just my normal like
talking voices if i'm like responding to
chat and
sure enough they eventually just go away
because that's what they want in the end
the
in the end they want you to be like how
[ __ ] dare you say something like that
you're such an [ __ ]
i already worry too much about it yeah
do what i want to do yeah but like you
know a lot of streams were just starting
off
you know can't really process that right
that you're just you're just buying into
the bait
it's hard to wrap your head around that
people are just gonna do mean things to
you
yeah and you don't know why yeah it's
nothing personal there's nothing
personal people just do this
that's part of the job right yeah i
could i could like there's someone out
there who i have no idea who they are i
have no interaction with them ever i've
never spoken to them
and for some reason they just want to
see bad [ __ ] happen to me
yeah i'm like that's that's really
difficult to accept that that's a
reality
yeah because it takes you a few years i
think you to like actually accept that
yeah
right absolutely i i don't know when i
started just kind of like getting over
it and just being like all right you
know what
it's gonna happen i feel like it was
like two or three years ago i was just
like probably when it happened enough
times and
it's you just kind of get used to it
yeah you realize you're sad enough
yeah you can't do anything about it you
just gotta you know not let it ruin your
day yeah you just have to like you think
about it logically right you've been
like well i've
never interacted with this person i
don't know what this person looks like
or what they're like as a person
i don't know what they look like right
i've never interacted with them so
they're obviously not saying
all this [ __ ] out of any logical basis
yeah so why would i take any logical
basis out of what
that's true that's true it also makes me
sad as well cause i'm like man if they
actually just spoke to me i'm sure
they'd probably see
yeah exactly a nice guy and they
wouldn't want to do this you know like i
just i don't know
yeah exactly